le plus grave est passé un je dirais les
sorties à midi on a mangé lasagnes au
bord de la piscine
elle a très très bien gaulée alors non
mais juste non mais elle va mieux loin
dames et c'est vrai qu'on a une vidéo
utilise de loana qui s'explique donc
pour la première fois depuis le gros
souci qu'a lieu la semaine dernière l'a
choisi tpmc pour s'expliquer forcément
et c'est bien elle qui a demandé à éric
de transmettre le message en question
regarde coucou tpm pc loana je tenais à
vous dire que les messages que vous avez
vu ce week-end ce sont bien les miens
c'est bien moi qui les ai écrits c'est
eric qui a transmis communaux transmis
la vidéo parce que j'avais pas internet
donc voilà c'est un peu mon pigeon
voyageur alors ah la la déjà en forme
mais elle a le sourire et ça c'est une
envie réelle et hyper important ensuite
à la cus donc silure tega de lui avoir
volé des choses regarde par contre je
tenais à rajouter à la tension de sylvie
que ma valise et étrangement vides ils
manquent de mes bijoux à voir aux as et
barda ou petits fermiers temps jusqu'à
mi slip
j'en ai même plus une j'ai plus de
pilotes plus de fer à friser plus de
bijoux les plus rien dans ma valise
la réal est vide une valise vide
étrangement et tu étais 7 kg était à
côté de moi dans la chambre d'hôtel
je vais porter plainte aussi pour vol de
tous mes bijoux que si mais après dans
ma valise
alors c'est vrai qu'on sache là il ya eu
un changement de cap pour loana
incroyable on verra s'il vire il ya une
prise de conscience dans les derniers
jours de loana par rapport à sylvie
ortega moi j'ai retracé le parcours je
sais qui et les a mises en contact
c'était en septembre dernier c'est un
certain nicolas je vais donner que ça
fait combien de tonnes auxquelles ce
qu'elles se connaissent septembre pas
plus nicolas c'est le garçon qu'on avait
vu dans le documentaire
voilà quelqu'un avait été voir à cannes
n'a pas et non c'est un autre chose un
autre nom et non celle dans le fret de
ces le père heures narcissique il a
ainsi lancé un autre
ok elle ne se connaissaient j'ai un
sonore ou un loan a dit silver tegan et
qu'une copine de soirée et puis en
septembre par ce jeune homme que je vais
rencontrer loana est entré dans la vie
de sylvie ortega et c'est vrai que
maintenant il faut le dire on l'a déjà
un petit la dernière fois
elle est entrée dans la vie de loana
pour manipuler loana prendre de l'argent
sur le dos de loana est sans doute au
début avec l'accord de loana la
maintenir sous dépendance médicamenteuse
donc lohan est aujourd'hui s'en rend
compte il ya une manipulation de la part
de silver tes gars qui est entré dans la
vie de cette jeune femme et c'est c'est
j'ai trouvé voilà d'après tous les
témoins que j'ai eu ce week-end il ya
vraiment une organisation de la part de
là lors on a notre extrait de loi n'a on
passe tout de suite à la dernière partie
de l'émission et loana a fait une mise
au point sur son overdose puisque
l'histoire on a on va venir ça paraît
colonna avait pris jeu du ghb
c'est ce que vous nous aviez dit
guillaume genton la veille de son
hospitalisation et que s'il dit
justement lui avait administré des
médicaments pour essayer de la soigner
ces sales histoires aux passés pour la
vienne elle a fait une crise suite à des
drogues qu'elle aurait consommé et
sylvie effectivement lui aurait donné
des médicaments suite à cette crise
c'est vrai c'est ce qui s'est passé est
la philo c'est parce que dit luan à
regarder ensuite de dire que je fais une
overdose ghb est je tiens à vous
préciser que je n'ai pas pris de drogue
et que je les analyse pour le projet non
ça a été à la faute de cause de
médicaments que j'ai eu ce coma de
plusieurs heures qui aurait pu me coûter
la vie
après comment est-ce que je les ai pris
moi je n'avais pas d'ordonnancé n'avait
pas de médicaments je les avais oubliés
à la maison je n'ai pas pris de drogue
des papes et d'alcool forcément c'est
bien quelqu'un qui me les a données
maintenant y'a plus personne et je le
portais plomb peuvent plainte pour
diffamation parce que je n'ai pas pris
de drogue ce jour là et ce sont des
médicaments qui m'ont mis dans le coma